[Música]
no sé son las felicitaciones
internacionales a manuel ma contras la
reelección del domingo ahora la atención
se centra en las elecciones legislativas
de junio que determinó la composición de
la asamblea y por tanto la
gobernabilidad para este segundo mandato
en ucrania hay una posibilidad real de
una guerra nuclear según el canciller
ruso sérguei lávrov no obstante el
funcionario aseguró que este tipo de
conflicto es inadmisible para moscú
desde kiev los secretarios de estado y
defensa de eeuu informaron que
washington reabrirá su embajada
próximamente anunciaron ayuda adicional
por más de 700 millones de dólares
un tribunal del estado de texas en eeuu
suspendió la ejecución de melissa lució
una mujer sentenciada muerta hace 14
años por el fallecimiento de su hija ma
raya de 2 años la defensa argumenta que
la niña murió por una lesión cerebral
tras caer por una escalera el caso será
revisado por una corte inferior
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en francia y
hacemos un recorrido por las reacciones
internacionales a la reelección de
manuel marco como presidente de europa
eeuu pasando por ucrania y rusia los
mensajes han sido mayormente positivos
la rapidez de las reacciones muestra el
alivio apenas se anunciaron los
resultados
numerosos jefes de estado felicitaron al
presidente
empezando con el mandatario ucraniano
volodymyr selenski en francés el jefe de
estado se alegró de la victoria de un
amigo de ucrania felicidades a manuel
macro en un real amigo de ucrania por su
reelección le deseo nuevos éxitos por el
bien del pueblo francés aprecio su apoyo
y estoy convencido que seguiremos
avanzando juntos hacia victorias comunes
hacia una europa fuerte y unida alivio
más que todo del lado europeo donde la
posible elección de imagen le preocupaba
la presidenta de la comisión europea o
sula donde la ley en dijo estar
encantada y él considera alemán olaf
scholz vio en este voto un mensaje
fuerte de los franceses a favor de
europa del lado británico el escrutinio
de continuidad es una buena noticia
especialmente de cara a la crisis
ucraniana así kids bring the wizarding
acabes creo que es muy importante que
tengamos en parís a un presidente en
quien se pueda confiar especialmente
frente a los desafíos internacionales
más importantes
y particularmente con respecto a la
situación en ucrania del agua ni los
words bin laden y raid en la guerra en
ucrania y la perspectiva de una unidad
occidental renovada son también el fondo
del mensaje de dubai den en twitter
felicidades a enmanuel macrón por su
reelección francia es nuestro aliado más
antiguo y un socio clave para asumir los
retos mundiales me alegro de la
continuación de nuestra estrecha
cooperación especialmente respecto al
apoyo a ucrania la defensa de la
democracia y la lucha contra la crisis
climática y reacciones más moderadas del
lado ruso el kremlin se conformó con un
mensaje lacónico varias horas después
del anuncio de los resultados deseando
también salud al presidente makoun el
contrato de europa como en 2017 el
presidente reelegido llegó al campo de
marte en parís para su discurso de
victoria con el himno europeo
hablamos ahora de la ofensiva rusa en
ucrania las fuerzas de moscú continuaron
sus ataques y bombardeos en diferentes
puntos de la geografía ucraniana entre
ellos mariupol en el sur y él vive en el
oeste del país en la jornada 5 personas
perdieron la vida los ataques mientras
la comunidad internacional continúa
dando su apoyo al gobierno de kiev a
través de la diplomacia hasta la capital
ucraniana llegaron los secretarios de
estado de defensa de eeuu y anunciaron
la reapertura próxima de la embajada
además de una ayuda adicional de más de
700 millones de dólares para ucrania
este lunes las fuerzas rusas siguieron
atacando a la planta siderúrgica de asof
tal en mariupol donde están refugiados
combatientes ucranianos los habitantes
de la ciudad esperan más bombardeos por
julio tenemos que restaurar la ciudad
después de todo este juego de guerra
pueden ver por ustedes mismos como es
ahora está tranquila pero solo por ahora
estoy y calor donde más bien fija otros
bombardeos fueron reportados en
instalaciones pero viales de la región
de venecia en el centro del país matando
a por lo menos cinco personas mientras
que una explosión provocó el incendio de
la estación de krasni cerca del vivir la
comunidad internacional sigue apoyando a
ucrania
anthony blinken anunció el regreso
progresivo de los diplomáticos
estadounidenses del país en una
conferencia de prensa en polonia tras
haber viajado a kiev por parte de
nuestro compromiso de cara al futuro
implica una serie de cosas que pude
compartir con el presidente saleh es que
ayer incluyendo el regreso de los
diplomáticos estadounidenses a ucrania a
partir de la próxima semana
eeuu también anunció una nueva ayuda
militar 700 millones de dólares el
secretario general de las naciones
unidas antonio guterres estuvo en
turquía donde fue recibido por el
presidente erdogán esta semana también
viajará a moscú y kiev mientras que el
embajador adjunto de rusia antes la onu
dmitry polyansky rechazó la posibilidad
de un alto el fuego en ucrania no
creemos que un alto al fuego sea una
buena opción en este momento porque la
única ventaja que dará es la posibilidad
de que las fuerzas ucranianas se
reagrupen y lleven a cabo más
provocaciones como la de
rusia sigue acusando sin pruebas a
ucrania deber creador de 60 las matanzas
de civiles en lucha en otras noticias el
presidente de brasil jair bolsonaro
argumentó que liberará a inocentes ha
sido defendió el controversial indulto
que le otorgó a daniel silveira un
diputado bolsón arista por río de
janeiro que fue condenado a ocho años y
nueve meses de cárcel por promover actos
antidemocráticos
el decreto de gracia e indulto es
constitucional y se cumplirá se hará
cumplir no pasa en el pasado liberaron
bandidos y nadie habló de eso hoy liberó
a inocentes
lo que queremos de los poderes de brasil
es que miren a brasil y no al poder si
cada poder quiere disputar la
presidencia puede cada uno y cada poder
sí que se ha disputado presidencia
también
hay varios partidos que ofrecen vacantes
tal vez esta persona sea la tercera
opción vamos a eeuu donde el foco se
centra en el caso de melissa lució una
mujer estadounidense de origen mexicano
que en 2007 fue condenada por la muerte
de su hija de dos años el miércoles iba
a recibir la inyección letal pero una
corte de apelaciones suspendió la
ejecución y la ordenó un tribunal menor
que revise el caso
cristóbal vázquez corresponsal de france
24 nos contó detalles de este proceso y
porque hasta ahora se suspende la
ejecución
sí melissa luz yo llevaba 14 años en el
corredor de la muerte muy poca gente
conocía de su caso hasta que pues hubo
un documental un documental de un
documentalista francesa que pues se puso
este caso en la luz pública el
documental se llama lúcio versus el
estado de texas en este documental pues
la documentalista muestra errores
judiciales errores judiciales y efecto
de este documental que llegó incluso
hasta los oídos de kim kardashian y de
otras personalidades acá en eeuu que se
pronunciaron para que le dieran el
perdón a melissa lució entre otros
fallos judiciales pues hay que resaltar
el tema de el interrogatorio que se hizo
inmediatamente después de que declararan
muerta su bebé su línea más allá de dos
años la policía los paramédicos le
informan a la policía que hay algo raro
porque hay muchos moretones en el cuerpo
de la menor y pues hay un dolor de
cabeza un golpe en la cabeza que la
menor sufrió
de 14 pisos que cayó esta menor y pues
entonces cuando me dije cuando melissa
lució habla con los paramédicos y
explica qué fue lo que pasó lo explica
en una casa diferente a donde estaban
donde estaban esa escalera de 14 pisos
donde cayó esa bebé lo que dice los
paramédicos en esa nueva casa que apenas
tenía 23 escaleras es que era imposible
que ese golpe en la cabeza fuera causado
por tres escalones esto escala de forma
que se sale de control se hace el
interrogatorio las autoridades hacen es
territorio ese mismo día y ese mismo día
pues está en este interrogatorio melissa
lució termina por presiones de las
autoridades diciendo que qué bueno que
al hablar mejor si era culpable pero lo
negó casi cien veces antes de decir esto
que terminó siendo la prueba para que le
dieran la la pena capital
pasamos a perú el presidente pedro
castillo presentó al congreso un
proyecto de ley de reforma
constitucional la propuesta busca que
una asamblea constituyente de lavore una
nueva carta magna por lo que el
mandatario pidió que se realice un
referendo en el que se le pregunta a los
ciudadanos si están de acuerdo o no si
es aprobado por los legisladores la
consulta se celebraría en octubre en
medio de las elecciones municipales sin
embargo la presidenta del congreso maría
del carmen alba ya calificó de
inconstitucional e inviable la
iniciativa
este es un tema que no está en la
constitución es inconstitucional
podría ser
este ejecutivo siempre ha querido ser
halcones o nunca que yo gobernar con el
congreso así llegamos al final de este
informativo pero volvemos en breve con
más noticias aquí en france 24
[Música]